>> male presenter: I would like to introduce
David Brin, who is, despite that trip, still
alive.
David Brin has been a science fiction author
for a very long time.
As a result of having a fair amount of insight,
over the years written books like, "Earth"
and has ended up working as a scientist with
groups like NASA and JPL, over the years doing
very ordinary kind of scientific work as well
as doing the kind of science fiction work
that people like me appreciate.
He's recently been working on a book called,
"Existence, " which seems to bare some resemblance
to other books he has written, but, that books
not out yet.
It will be coming out in June.
So, probably you're looking forward to it
as much as I am.
He sent us an excerpt for us to read, which
I have the suspicion a fair amount of people
have looked at.
And thank you very much for coming.
[applause]
>> David Brin: Sure thing.
>> David Brin: What Alex doesn't mention is
that we've known each other a long time.
Back when I lived in England.
Back in the mid-1980s, I lived in London for
a couple of years.
Very interesting times.
The Thatcher years.
[laughter]
And later on when I finished "Earth," my then
fiancé got her doctorate at Cal Tech.
We packed up our belongings and we had to
be at her post doc in Paris in six weeks.
So, we took the long way around the world.
If you ever go to India, don't get a round
trip without first looking into an around
the world pass.
I don't know if they're still done the same,
but you can take an entire year to finish
it, zigzagging around the world.
And we arrived back in L.A. a year to the
day after we left in order to get married.
She still says, "You never gave me a honeymoon."
[laughter]
Well, because most of the trips after that
were with kids.
I said, "I took you to Easter Island.
I took you to Australia.
I took you around the world."
And she says, "That was before we were married."
[laughter]
The day after we were married, we went on
a plane to the number one honeymoon spot in
the world.
And she said, "That was going home to our
apartment in Paris."
[laughter]
A hard woman, but worth it.
OK.
So, I'm going to do just a lot of song and
dance just about ideas because here I feel
very much at home.
I feel very much at home at Google.
And besides, which I was born about 20 miles
from here.
So, went to L.A. High.
Same high school as Ray Bradbury.
As a matter of fact, the one time my kids
gave me unalloyed respect for a two-hour stretch,
all three of them at the same time, was when
I took them to meet Ray at his house.
He got up from his walker, "David."
"That was Ray."
Two hours, solid respect, amazing.
[laughter]
OK.
So, in any event, a hometown crowd.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to leap
and hope and jump around.
So, what I'm best known for is the science
fiction novels.
"Postman" was Kevin Costner-ized.
Don't ask me about that.
[laughter]
"Earth " is credited with having web pages
two years before the web was invented.
Big deal.
For a lot of us it seemed obvious where the
world was going.
"Transparent Society " is one of the only
public policy books from the 20th Century
that's still in print and still selling more
every year, partly because of some very, very
creepy prescient predictions that came true.
Partly because it's one of the only places
that is standing up for "sousveillance" as
a solution to our modern information problems.
Rather than trying to use, as the Europeans
want, use law to protect people's privacy.
As a short-term solution, I don't object to
such things.
Over the long term, it's not going to work.
The most recent book, which is coming out
with the cover on the left, in the States,
and in the really creepy ominous cover on
the right.
It's going to be in 3D, by the way.
They're going to use new experimental process
in Britain for the cover of "Existence "there.
And both of them will have this.
I'm going to tell you guys for the first time.
I just found out about it.
Big, nice, glowing cover blurb from, Temple
Grandin.
How about that?
Have you ever heard of her?
>> male #1: [inaudible]
>> David Brin: Most, well, the--.
Yeah.
The Clair Danes movie.
Most famous autistic person in the world.
OK.
But I'm going to get to talking about something
entirely different.
And now for something completely different.
I'm gonna talk about the big picture.
Now, here's a big picture asp.
One, just one of many.
And that is the fact that for the last 500
years, western civilization has been having
breakthrough after breakthrough having to
do with three things.
And that is our ability to see, our ability
to know, and our ability to allocate our attention.
And the first of these crises was precipitated
by lenses, which empowered the ability to
see.
The printing press, which expanded the public's
access to knowledge and perspective.
This is a little more complicated than this,
because about the same time the discovery
of the Americas and the vastness of the world
also have major effects upon people.
Now each time, I'm gonna race through this,
each time what happened was, you had augmentations
of memory, vision, and attention.
And one might also argue reach.
Because your ability to do physical things
expanded as well.
But these are the three I'm paying attention
to.
And the result was not always an expansion
of people's wonderfulness, kindness, or even
empathy.
Empathy did come from eventually, from augmentations
of memory, vision, and attention.
But not at first.
At first, these things were used for polemic.
And the printed books that were produced after
Gutenberg's era for 150 years, tended to exacerbate
social problems.
To exacerbate hatreds.
And each time a quandary was developed, the
Renaissance versus rage of doctrine, and new
concepts spread.
The notion of progress.
The notion of the value of an individual.
Now I'm not going into these in detail, but
down here at the bottom, the knowledge mesh
is expanding our ability to have access to
memory in profound ways.
It's almost as if you remember that.
This or that or the other.
Omniveillance, television was one of the major--
radio and then television; these were major
forces that drove our ability to empathize
with people far away.
Radio, the broadcasts of Edward R. Murrow
from the London Blitz helped to convince Americans
to get involved in World War II.
Coverage from Vietnam helped to convince Americans
that this was not an undertaking that seemed
very worthwhile.
Visualization, simulation and gaining, these
are all areas in which we are running into
the crisis that Linda Stones talks about when
she speaks of continuously divided attention.
And as a parent of a kid in high school, who
wants to do his homework while Facebook is
up and while listening to music on the headphones,
I have to explain, "No, this may not be the
best approach."
And yet his generation insists that it is.
The-.
But you see my attitude is always the attitude
of the grouchy earlier generation.
And that is that the people are not going
to be able to adapt.
With each new tech wave, godlike expansions
of vision, knowledge, attention and reach
led to fear of hubris.
Trying to take on God's power, or self-destruction.
Future shock.
I think your neighbor Alvin Toffler here in
town deserves to be considered one of the
great visionaries of the 20th Century.
Because it's very clear that for the first
decade of the 21st Century, America has been
in horrible shape.
State of future shock.
At least a third of our citizens don't want
to have anything to do with the new era and
the new century.
Which leads to cause for renunciation and
control by a trusted elite.
This is something I go into in "Existence."
And yet despite painful adjustment we never
refuse these new prosthetics.
Always these godlike powers become the new
norm.
Now who would have imagined that we would
be able to with this ape-like, or Garden of
Eden like, this ape-like organ in here to
be able to adapt to these floods of information,
vision, attention.
Well, part of the answer is that as Carl Sagan
pointed out, we share the medulla and the
cerebellum with fish.
The mammalian cortex is laid upon it.
The primate cortex is laid upon that.
The portions that we share with apes are layed
upon that.
But then you go farther and what you get is
something that is just above the eyes.
Little nubs above the eyes.
Who can name them?
The prefrontal lobes.
The prefrontal lobes are the organs that we
now know are the organs of the future.
They are the seat of what Einstein called
the Gedanken experiment, or thought experiment.
Relativity was 50 percent him imagining riding
a streetcar at the speed of light leaving
the burning clock tower.
And figuring out where all the rays would
go and where they would arrive.
Only the-- only 50 percent of it was math.
And he left half of that to his wife.
The point is that the Gedanken experiment
is what you do when you think with these prefrontal
lobes.
What would happen if I raised this at the
meeting today?
What would happen if I wear this?
What would happen if I tried to run this yellow
light?
And as you guys, you males know, we have to
make those decisions about these Gedanken
experiments all the time.
We're constantly saying, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah.
Now we know about this because pre-frontal
lobotomies, they are snipped and people lose
the interest in doing these thought experiments
about what they're going to do.
They remain intelligent people.
But that's why I would much rather have a
free bottle in front of me, than a pre-frontal
lobotomy.
All right.
I saw the head shakes starting there.
[laughter]
The point is that this layering effect is
arguably, what we are doing with these prosthetics.
We're simply adding external layering's onto
this layered set of cortexes that has already
been taking place.
And that is one theory to explain why we have
so gracefully adapted to orders of magnitude.
Increases in our ability to know, remember,
to see, and pay attention.
I'm going to veer aside a little bit and get
even more general here.
Most human civilizations were shaped like
this.
A few lords at the top lording it over vast
numbers of peasants below.
And what was in the interest of those rulers?
These were the allocators.
And it made some sense for a while, because
we had very little surplus, frequent starvation.
If you're going to have any kid live his whole
life without ever having an episode in which
his brain was starving, it might as well be
the kids of the priests and the lords.
You had to have somebody.
And so feudalism made some sense.
And Locke's social contracts was, just rule
us well or we have the right to cut off your
head and replace you with somebody else.
It seems likely to rule us well.
That's the implicit social contract of Locke.
Now we are supposedly moving toward what Heinlein
prescribed as the explicit social contract.
Where every 19 year old will negotiate with
the state and sign a contract.
And if not interested in living by this contract,
go someplace else and sign a looser contract.
Heinlein laid that out and it's a very interesting
potential end point for this process from
the implicit to the explicit social contract.
And we're not going to go there at all today.
The point is that this was all an attractor
state propelled by Darwin and human nature.
Once you're allured up there, it is in your
own Darwinian self-interest to persuade hundreds
and thousands of virile young males to go
off and fight and die to protect your seraglio
for you.
And the awesome thing is we're all descended
from guys who pulled that shit off.
[laughter]
They actually succeeded at that.
We're descended from the harems of guys like
that.
Wow.
So this is a major, major attractor state.
And I defy you to take Dungeons and Dragons
dice, go home, roll up random decades across
the last 6000 years, and random locations.
Any place that had metallurgy and agriculture,
big males teamed up, picked up metal instruments
and took other men's women and wheat.
Find for me the exceptions.
Even the Soviet Union was run by nomenklatura
that acted exactly like the czarist ruling
class.
The alternative is called the Western Enlightenment.
And it is very, very different in a number
of ways.
Including its shape.
The first human civilization in which the
well off outnumber the poor.
And therefore, the poor is a small enough
portion of the population that we feel guilty
about it.
That we feel something can be done.
Instead of a bitter sea that could never be
drained, it's a bitter lake.
And therefore somebody's fault.
In every way, it's different.
The Churn effect.
The notion that no one should inherit automatically
the status of their parents.
And the fact that we believe in the positive
sum game that the rising tide will lift all
boats.
Now, one can argue that we are in a position
right now that our parents faced and their
parents faced and their parents faced.
Because this is inherently unstable.
If it's an attractive state-- attractor state,
it is a meta- stable attractor state.
And every single generation, some of those
who got rich by these methods, do their best
to try to make it into a pyramid.
Because it's in our genes.
I don't think the Koch brothers are inherently
evil for obeying what their genes tell them
to do.
We just have to stop them.
[laughter]
Our parents did.
Their parents did.
The Enlightenment is over 200 years old I'll
have you know.
Do you know what the first acts, political
acts, done by our founding fathers as soon
as the Treaty of Ghent was signed and the
United States was officially independent?
Two things.
A seizure and distribution of over one third
of the land in the colonies.
And an utter ban of prima geniture.
You could not for 100 years leave all of your
belongings to a single child.
It was fiercely- it's not fiercely enforced
today, but it was fiercely enforced then.
Because they had, the large families divide
it up equally.
Your oligarchy problem goes away.
Most people don't realize how radical our
founders were about this notion.
Now, here's another big concept for you.
You have hierarchical institutions.
We've had them since Sumeria.
Since the pharaohs.
And, these are inherently pyramidal.
You have commander in chief.
You have pyramidal structures that are supposed
to do various things, enhancing their communications.
Among these various portions of our government
is something I've been consulted on, and you
guys are engaged in that as well.
Here you have a different type of institution.
Here you have the four accountability arenas.
Accountability arenas are the driving engine
behind the enlightenment.
They harness creative competition, the greatest
force for creativity in the history of- in
nature.
We are all result of creative competition.
Darwinism made us and creative competition
isn't necessarily sweet.
It isn't necessarily fair.
Usually in the last 6000 years when it took
place in marketplace, we wound up with lords
who then tried to cheat to prevent further
competition from happening.
But instead to have their own kids, own other
people's kids.
The brilliance of democracy, markets, science,
and law courts is that they are designed to
harness competitiveness through ritualized
combat.
In each case, there is highly ritualized regulated
form of combat that minimizes the blood and
waste on the floor.
But maximizes rewards to those who actually
deliver a better product and service.
Now, in some cases like markets, it's inefficient
and not always accurate.
But we can afford that in order to have it
be more freewheeling.
But supposedly, you aren't supposed to be
able to wind up at the end of a round of competition
with a monopoly that would then stop all further
competition.
Instead, once you've created the new product
of service it's supposed to engender more.
And if this is not what's happening then something
is wrong with the regulations of the system.
Same is true with democracy.
Democracy can be filthy.
You can get wrong results.
Boy, can you.
But the point is, that supposedly you wind
up-.
Look, 2012 is the year that Robert Heinlein
forecast in his "Future History" back in the
60s and 50s that America would be taken over
by a fellow named, Nehemiah Scudder.
Ever heard of him?
Oh, you really need to know more sci-fi.
Nehemiah Scudder does not even win a plurality.
But a Supreme Court decision gets him the
Presidency anyway.
I think we're mixing this with a different
year.
And then he clamps down, shuts down the constitution,
declares himself Prophet of The Lord.
And there is a 70 year theocracy in America.
Very, very chilling.
The point is that each of these has its own
rituals and that's why we usually don't think
of them in parallel, but their similarities
outweigh their differences.
There's always a centrifugal phase in which
through safety you can prepare your product.
Your company, your political party, attorney
client privilege, or your laboratory and your
tenure in science but then there is ritualized
call to battle.
The scientific conference, the publication,
the marketplace, the court trial and the degree
of ritualization is determined by the need,
or not need, for explicit accuracy.
In courts, everything is extremely meticulous
because you can't afford a more than one percent
error rate but it keeps things slow.
All right.
Didn't need to get going on that.
What I really care about is this one.
You can see that these are entirely different
processes.
This is the old pyramidal structure of decision
making, hierarchical decision making.
We have needs for it, but it should devolve
to here wherever possible.
Here you have structured competition.
Here you have the people.
And this is where web is starting to make
a difference in the ability of people to converse
and their ability to get involved in the problem
solving process and perhaps lead to an age
of amateurs.
Now we spoke of the lamps on the brow, if
you're ever in Rome be sure to visit the greatest
piece of sculpture ever carved.
Michelangelo's sculpture of Moses.
It's a few- it's about ten blocks away from
the Vatican in a little side church.
It's amazing.
You swear he's about to stand up.
And he's formidable.
He makes you look like a little guy.
OK.
So the main reason why I show this slide is,
I do a lot of consulting for the Defense Department,
Defense Threat Reduction Agency, CIA.
After this trip, I go off to the Air Force.
And I talk about the Professional Protector
Caste.
The Professional Protector Caste has had its
budget increased tremendously since 9/11.
And yet here's the interesting thing, on 9/11
they failed completely at what they aimed
to do.
And that's use these prefrontal lobes.
To try to anticipate using data collection,
total information awareness.
You've heard about the new two billion dollar
facility NSA is building in Utah.
To hear everything and then analyze it and
then proactively act on dangers.
Fine.
God bless them.
As long as they are subject to scrutiny and
sousveillance.
That's s-o-u-s- veillance.
That means looking from below.
Surveillance means looking from above.
Incredibly important term.
I helped Steve Mann coin it some years ago.
Very important term.
If we have sousveillance and supervision on
these professional protectors, then we will
have a choke chain to remind it- the watchdog-it's
a dog and not a wolf.
I need to be less chaotic here and spontaneous
because these things get recorded.
[laughter]
It's just- Ahh.
But the other thing is to remember, is that
anticipation wasn't even involved on 9/11.
Every single act performed by our professional
protector cast on that day failed.
There was not a single success by any level
of professional protectors that day.
Including the brave heroes in the New York
Fire Department.
Remind me to get a link so you can see my
abortive TV show that I was supposedly going
to be one of the stars of, called "Architecs",
without a T. In which we slept in New York's
fire stations and interviewed the surviving
heroes of Rescue 1.
And their comrades went charging into those
buildings.
Very brave.
Didn't work.
What worked?
I'll tell you what worked.
Soon as I can get it.
This worked.
Average citizens out in the street saying,
"I know the 911 operators are telling you
to stay by your desk and help is on the way.
Get out!"
30,000 lives saved by that.
It was New Yorkers who fought the fires when
the professionals died.
And it was people armed with this stuff that
rebelled, who rebelled on Flight UA 93.
Ending the war that day because the war was
a test of our manhood.
It is- it was essentially.
Every decade Americans are challenged by opponents
who believe in the zero sum game.
The fundamental ethos of the West and of the
Western Enlightenment is the positive sum
game.
If you must read any book during the next
year read Robert Wright's "NONZERO."
That explains the distinction between these
two things.
In a zero sum game, if I win a point, you've
lost a point.
The positive sum game, I'm going to get rich
making Google and all my employees are going
to get rich just a little less than me.
And all the people out there are gonna have
plenty of opportunity to get richer because
we set everything up.
We all benefit from the positive sum game.
Well, the point is there are many cultures
in which people are not raised assuming positive
sum games.
So, they look at America and they say, "You
guys are rich, you're happy, sexy.
You must have traded something for it.
"Hitler said so.
The south said so.
The Soviets said so.
So on, and so on.
Every generation makes this calculation and
says, "Americans, they have all this stuff
but they're decadent.
They have no manhood.
They have no courage.
They have no guts."
And the heroes on Flight UA 93 disproved it
that afternoon.
They won the war.
Through the other thing, you have anticipation
and then you have resilience.
So this is Steve Mann.
This is the goggles arrangement he had in
1980.
And it got smaller, smaller, smaller.
And now of course, you guys are doing it.
And this is a character from my new novel
where she has these little cyber activated
doogies that come up and look around in all
directions out of her hair.
You can barely make out the stuff going on,
on the inside.
And at lunch we were talking about how the
tooth clickers and the sub vocal checkers,
and all that sort of thing.
And the main thing is, that-.
Oh, have you heard about the latest DARPA
Challenge?
These annual things, a couple of years ago
it was to find the red balloons.
And the-.
Last year it was to remake shredded documents.
This year's it's the challenge, and there's
a team in San Diego you could join if you
want to, is to track five teams of fake jewel
thieves all across America and Europe and
to catch images of them.
So the notion is you get smart mobs.
And if you had read that scene, those scenes
that Alex told you about.
Some scenes from "Earth", and some scenes
from my new novel, you'd see this in action.
But this is from Patrick Farley's wonderful
web comic called "Spiders".
Where basically this little girl in America
is the one who finds Osama.
This was pre Osama dying.
Back when I was at Cal Tech as an undergraduate,
we were worried about something called the
overspecialization problem.
It seems logical.
It seemed to be completely where things were
going.
And that is the notion that the-.
Every year we know more, and more, and more.
Right?
Chemical abstracts used to be all on paper.
And when the chemical abstracts would come
out every year, would be bigger, and bigger,
and bigger.
And these are just abstracts of chemical papers.
What does this mean?
It means that every year in order to be a
specialist about something, good enough to
get a PhD, you have to know more and more
about less, and less.
It seemed an unstoppable trend.
And with the vocabulary getting narrower and
narrower, you would not know if someone in
the next building over there using a somewhat
different vocabulary was studying the same
thing you were.
So you get duplication of effort.
You get slowing down of accomplishment.
You're 60 years old before you know enough
to get your PhD.
It seems terrifying.
Likely, it seemed unstoppable.
There seemed to be no way out.
And now it seems that no one ever mentions
this anymore.
It seems a bizarre, quaint thing to ponder.
Now the way I just described to you, it sounds
logical.
And we may hit that wall again.
Why didn't we?
Well obviously, I was there at the beginnings
of computer literature searches and I could
see.
I could get links to things that were obscure
in various directions.
And the trick was, I had to do the Google
tricks myself and come up with different vocabulary
twists that would sometimes bring in things
from other departments.
But the other thing is that people got smarter.
Down at UCSD, we just won the right to establish
the Arthur C. Clark Center for Human Imagination.
It's gonna be wonderful.
All the deans in all the departments, art
sciences.
They've all signed on.
Cognitive Science and Neuroscience is gonna
study the process of imagination.
While getting involved the artists and the
authors.
And then determining new ways of using computers
to enhance the imaginative process in kids.
It's going to be very exciting and please
keep track of it.
OK?
We'll have an announcement by the summer.
But, the point is, that is reflective of cross
discipline.
Of breaking down of guild boundaries.
And the fact that, you guys there's a word
that starts with G.
It's become a verb and a noun.
The point is that, that is the principle way
in which people have been able to get past
the problem of narrow-minded overspecialization.
And now Nicholas Carr and the cyber grouches
are talking instead about a problem of broadminded,
scatterbrained, shallow mindedness.
And that's the doom and gloom scenario people
are talking about.
I'm sure you've all seen this cover of "Atlantic."
The notion that this is not necessarily making
us smarter; It's making us more aware.
But they aren't necessarily the same things.
Wish I had time to go into that in more detail.
Now we won't go into huge detail about the
big picture issue.
But another important book from the last few
years, get you nice and depressed about how
likely it is that we're going to have a collapse
of human civilization.
The opposite extreme, the singularitarians,
as a contrarian who loves to be in the presence
of people he can say, "yes" back to you know,
libertarians who I can sound like a liberal.
Liberals I can tell about Adam Smith.
This is the golden age for me.
I was garroted and burned at the stake in
all of my other lives.
I get to live to be in my 60s and see my kids.
And get paid for this because--yeah, but.
Yes, but.
The people who think we are all gonna be gods
in 25 years, remind me of Porgy and Bess,
" It ain't necessarily so."
OK.
The one big perspective thing that pins it
all is the Fermi paradox.
And that is the question of why we see no
signs of anybody out there.
The great big constructs that our descendants
may build, the visitations.
The earth was prime real-estate for two billion
years with a no oxygen atmosphere.
And nobody above the level of slime molds
to defend it.
Why in all these movies do they show up now?
[laughter]
The Drake Equation of course, in one of my
papers.
I've been engaged in this for 35 years.
And in one of my papers, which is the only
major review paper about the field, I expand
the Drake Equation because it doesn't predict
anything in that sense.
But the whole notion-.
You're all familiar with the Drake Equation
right?
The notion of the fraction of planets that
are out there.
The number of planets.
That's one part of the Drake equation that
has been expanded just in the last ten years.
It's amazing times to live in.
And we'll live to see whether or not there's
oxygen and methane on some of these atmospheres
and all that.
But whether or not this pale blue dot, by
the way I consider this picture of the earthrise
from the Apollo 8, from that horrible year,
1968.
It's like Pandora's Box got open.
All the evils leapt out and there was this
little gleam of hope at the bottom of the
box.
The Christmas message from the moon showing
a little oasis in space.
One of the two most important works of art
in the history of humanity and it was done
by scientists.
The other one was too.
Who can name it?
It changed us forever.
Changed our attitudes towards war.
The image of the Atom Bomb.
Both of them.
Because visual art is changing human hearts
and minds without verbal persuasion.
And the two most powerful symbols that changed
human hearts were the image of the Earth and
the Atom Bomb.
So, the question is, will there be life?
Will there be the development of intelligence?
Technological intelligence that survives a
series of traps.
A series of crises that might leave us like
Mars.
In fact, there's evidence that this is our
second planet.
We originally came from Mars.
Because, don't you want an extra hour every
day?
Because wouldn't you be happier with half
the gravity?
[laughter]
Huh?
We miss our homeland.
Let's just hope we don't do to this planet
what we did to that one.
The point is, I forget why I put that guy
there.
[laughter]
The point is, is there a great filter?
Why are the numbers small in the cosmos?
>> male #2: [inaudible]
>> David Brin: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
That's the honey pot.
The honey pot is one of the more popular notions
of, what keeps the-- It empty.
And that is, we all, all the races go down
into cyberspace.
And I don't believe it because if even one
race has a bunch of grouches who like to ride
motorcycles and are techies, then they'll
become Hell's Angels and they'll be the ones
who have the kids and go off into space.
Everybody will be descended from them.
While their distant cousins are back home,
ooooo, living forever in the web.
This whole question of whether the great filter
lies behind us.
And it may very well be that we are very rare
in our technological intelligence.
Or, it may be, catch me some other time, and
I believe there's a good chance of this, that
99 percent of life worlds are water worlds.
And that ours, with a lot of continental land
area, the ability to make hands and fire species
may be relatively rare.
You have the guys who think it's coming right
away.
Good old Ray, he's very optimistic because
he's one of the oldest of the singularitarians.
So he thinks it's gonna come in time for him.
And his younger colleagues are going "Oh Ray
sorry."
It's harder than you think.
Yeah.
It's going to be at least another 20 years
after that.
But in time for me.
[laughter]
So anyway, this gives you the whole range
of some of the possibilities.
He's a character in my new novel.
[laughter]
I couldn't resist.
Everything that you see to this slide show
is all in the new novel.
I want to get into some practical stuff that
is standing in our way of being resilient
civilization that practices the age of amateurs,
not in order to get rid of the professional
protectors.
But in order to augment them.
Because we are going to need healthy institutions.
We are going to need healthy accountability
arenas.
Those arenas, the markets, and courts, and
science, and democracy.
And we're going to need to have the enhanced
resiliency that comes from a fully empowered
populous.
In this argument that you saw.
In that Google is making us stupid thing.
You have the cyber grouches like Nicholas
Carr saying that.
It's not helping.
Clay Shirky and the cyber optimists are all
saying, "Look how many people are expressing
themselves.
All connected and expressing themselves."
And the average length of self-expression
goes smaller, and smaller, and smaller and
then had the major lobotomy down to 140 characters.
Another major lobotomy when Facebook made
the return an automatic post.
[laughter]
I could out do Facebook.
Just, just, 20 million dollars.
The point is, he's- they're both right.
Do you remember how I mentioned this pattern
in the accountability arenas that have developed
over the last 300 years?
A pattern of centrifugal gathering in safety.
Creating product, but then a ritualized call
to combat that could not be refused and would
result in maximizing the test of products,
while minimizing the cost that use to accrue
to that, to competition.
Death, blood on the floor, monopolization.
That pattern exists well in those old systems.
It's always under threat.
Several of them are under profound threat
right now in the west.
But, we'll deal with it.
We're no less people than our ancestors.
The point is that the internet is missing
half of it.
Think about it.
It's got this.
You've got people able to separate out into
little Nuremburg rallies.
They can argue.
They can stew.
They can perfect their product.
But war is the ritualized combat that makes
bad stuff go away.
I'm not talking about creating an elite that
says, "That's a bad idea, no one will discuss
it anymore."
I'm talking about a kind of ritualized combat
that made the Edsel go away.
Most of you don't get that.
So, what?
What's something more recent?
That really-.
[laughter]
>> male#3: Horror movies.
Myspace.
[laughter]
>> David Brin: All right, MySpace.
That makes inferior stuff go away.
How many of you have been on a blog in a comment
section?
And you wrote something that absolutely devastated
an untrue statement.
And a dozen other people said, "Right.
Yes.
Dead."
And the next day you see it again somewhere
else.
Nothing dies.
And death is how creative competition works.
All right.
Let's just go through a few of these.
Your phone.
This phone was the hero on 9/11.
On Katrina, and again at Fukushima.
You had hundreds of thousands of people with
these in their pockets, fully charged, unable
to do squat.
Fukushima they found several people had made
text messages and all of that they were clutching
their cell phones under rubble.
They'd had time-hours-nobody came.
The cell towers were down.
I go at this again, and again, and again in-
at these defense meetings.
It's insane.
All it would take is a simple law demanding
that Verizon and the others include a simple
crude baron packet switching, text passing,
tier-to-tier system in the cell phones.
You could even have it, so that if you don't
have a cell, it doesn't turn on unless-.
If you are detecting a nearby cell tower.
I think that's chicken shit.
I mean if you could not come up with a system
that would tattle tale along the way from
cell phone to cell phone and tell who passed
it on until it reached a cell tower, give
them a penny each and charge an extra nickel
to the person who sent it.
Then you don't deserve to be an engineer at
these companies.
You should be able to make money doing that.
[coughing]
But there's no excuse not to have it.
Think about it.
You're buried under a building, you can send
a text and then put it down go to sleep and
at some point when someone's passing by it
takes the text away.
With a few dozen repeaters across the Great
Plains and the Rockies, we could have a crude
telegraph system across the entire country
if all the cell towers were down.
But this should give the cell phone manufacturers
a way to go into that dark mile.
You can say in most places, you will be able-
even in the dark mile, you'd still be able
to send texts.
Especially if people are encouraged to leave
their phones at the edge.
Hooked and logged in, "Oh, I earned a buck
last night passing on"…
Why?
I talked to a vice president of Verizon; all
he could give me was just hate filled glares.
I couldn't even get why.
Other examples abysmal self-organizing software
on the internet.
No emergency modes of access.
There are people working on that.
There's all sorts of examples on the web where
you can see where there are people who are
working on possible Wi-Fi based systems.
Blue tooth based systems.
There are lots of other examples.
I'm putting solar on my roof right now.
I've been asking about this.
Do you know we have billions of people in
America with rooftop solar?
You know what happens in a power blackout.
It shuts off.
You cannot draw power from your own solar
roof in a power blackout.
There are some clues.
There are some rotten work-arounds that cost
thousands and thousands of dollars.
What would it take to come up with a box that
people could add to their solar system that
would power one plug inside their house?
With all sorts of warning labels on it.
You know, flashing lights and all of that.
Just for their fridge and their rechargers.
Why are we still vulnerable to EMP?
We've known about it for 40 years.
It would surprise you now, but say Newt Gingrich
was right about that.
Actually, he's the only one of the bunch who
would invite me to the White House.
[laughter]
Because he's a sci-fi fan.
He's a sci-fi author.
I mentioned the other sci-fi fan, Temple Grandin.
Dull, dull, dull cell phone designs!
Awwwww!
Horrible!
Stupid.
Oh, now I'm gonna take em-.
[laughter]
No.
Now I'm gonna show you what a cell phone design.
Show you this.
I'll talk meanwhile.
My son came up with this.
I was part of a workshop in which we talked
about snap-on phones.
In which you snap-on peripherals that could
do sensing.
That could do detecting.
That could put the laser display or the laser-projected
keyboard.
All these things that you aren't normally
using.
Interface.
Web interface.
You can see that-.
Let me tell you something, I am old.
Back in 1973, I sat at a teletype--there was
not a single computer monitor on the planet--
I sat at a teletype at Cal Tech and there
was one of the first networks in the world.
A computer.
A couple of other computers on campus.
And I typed away at the teletype and in black
ink, D-B, colon, and part of what I said.
Interrupted, C-K, colon, in red.
What someone else was saying.
Then, R-L, colon, and what someone else was
saying.
And, D-B, finishing what I had typed.
Now, here's the weird part.
All of you know exactly what I am talking
about.
It wasn't at all surprising.
You understood exactly what I am saying.
Why?
Because sometime in the last few months you
did exactly that.
Why did you whippersnappers have a clue what
I was talking about?
Alternating, interrupting, scrolling chat.
I'm sorry the example here is Myspace, but
it's the same damn thing.
Lobotomization, lobotomization, lobotomization.
Have you ever been to Second Life?
I've had some of the most populated events
ever there.
I'm sitting on stage, interviewing away.
Wonderful buxom bods out there.
And the actual exchange of informational content
is down here in the low half alternating,
interrupting scrolling chat.
Now in fact, conversation goes back to the
Neolithic.
I think our ancestors had cocktail parties.
Seriously.
I mean, you knew where you usually had a successful
hunt.
You would send boys up ahead to gather firewood,
and to crush berries into gourds, and hang
them way up high in the trees.
You had this year's successful hunt, you drag
the carcass over, you'd start the firewood,
and you invite the Ugrug tribe over, pulled
down the gourds and chat.
We're good at it.
And you know how in a conversation you adjust
who you're talking to by proximity, by angle
of orientation, by your estimation of their
reputation.
>>male#4: [laughter]
>> David Brin: By the public estimation of
their reputation.
By how interesting what they have to say is.
Whether its topic related.
But you've been in a restaurant and you've
seen when somebody mentions your name two
and three conversations away.
What happens?
It pops out of the buzz.
And you know, here's the scary part.
A sentence or two before your name came up.
Several words of lead in.
What does that mean?
It means your brain is providing services
to you.
Constantly sifting and controlling what enters
into your conscious awareness.
Now, all of these things that I've just described
to you-.
Ha Ha, this is very funny.
When are you going to stop wasting your time
with that science fiction nonsense and start
dealing with reality?
This being horse and cart.
Very funny.
We give high priority when we are able to
allocate our attention.
We adjust attention by, criteria, topic, time,
reputation, etcetera, etcetera.
The point is that everything I just described
to you is not existent in interaction on the
web.
Even though it's proved important and useful
in allocating what do we see, what we know
and how we pay attention in real life.
These are real life phenomena that have not
made it onto the web and I can prove that
to you.
If you look at the old Google Tech Talk, I'm
sorry I had a lot more caffeine that day.
[laughter]
And that's taking breaks with my co-deliverer,
Sheldon Brown.
He's going to be head of the Arthur C. Clark
Center For Human Imagination.
Well, what I did during that talk is I looked
at my watch and said, "I know because I was
just granted a patent."
It happened to be on the day that my patent
came through.
Every one of those things
I own.
Now, does that surprise you?
Does that make you skeptical?
Well, it should.
I don't expect any of those things.
Any of those claims to survive heavy-duty
attacks.
Undoubtedly, there is some graduate student
somewhere who adjusted screen allocation values
by reputation.
Another who did it by angle of orientation.
We even found a couple at IBM that we had
to modify the patents.
What the patent means is that nobody is currently
making a billion dollars off of us, those
things.
Nobody at all.
Let me see if I can remember where this goes.
How's this work?
Oh yeah, that's right.
That's right.
That goes there.
It's been a little while since I've done this.
It's gonna look a little awkward.
Now, you're all used to answering the phone
like this and emanating into the world.
How about, there's your watch.
This watch is on your watchband.
Ring ring, ring ring.
Ah shoot.
Hello? Microphone is here.
This happens to bring your phone right up
next to your ear.
Well, yeah, it did.
OK, hello?
Now you're covering your voice.
You're covering your mouth.
It will at least sell in Japan.
[laughter]
Now, hey take a look at this.
Oh wow, man that's incredible.
Hey.
[laughter]
It's just an example of where you gotta think,
people say outside the box.
You gotta think outside the playground.
Because group-think is everywhere.
Now, if you like, this is the Exorarium, I'd
love to set this up.
It is a both computer game and museum place
where you would go from creation station to
creation station.
And, you first choose your star, then your
solar system.
And then your planet and then your ecosystem.
And at the end of it you get your own alien.
And we were invited up to talk to Will Ryman
about his thing, "Spore."
Because he was way behind.
He was a couple years behind on "Spore" and
he was scared of us.
And so, we laughed and we said," if we had
four orders of magnitude and better funding,
you should be scared of us.
[laughter]
And so, he described to us "Spore" where you
buy attributes for your race.
And we said, "Oh, I see.
You do creative design.
We do evolution."
[laughs] Now I thought he'd laugh, but Sheldon
said, "No, no, no.
He was angry."
But, then you take your alien race down to
the extraterrestrial terrarium and you have
encounter scenarios.
You can do this online of course as a computer
game too.
You know, I would complain about the fraction
of my ideas that ever see real life.
Except for the fact that I have a fair number
of them that see real life.
And so, nobody's going to listen to me or
give me hearts and flowers.
It's frustrating.
I don't even get any pity.
So, my objective was to not be your typical
talk.
To not have a particular focus but to dance
around and poke at ideas.
That perhaps some of them you hadn't thought
of before.
Big perspective.
Are us.
Anybody?
>>male#5: Ok.
In that case, if you knew about Street View,
MySpace, and Facebook and other modern sharing
stuff that we've got now.
At the time, you had written "Transparent
Society", you'd had many of the ideas back
then but things have turned out a little bit
different in various ways.
How would you have written the book differently?
>> David Brin: It's all going inconsistently,
pretty much consistent.
I would have more examples.
The fact of the matter is that we are seeing
a drift towards hierarchical institutions
having more and more power to see.
The defenders of liberty are rightfully concerned
about that because the image that we have
of Big Brother with the telescreen, is pyramidal.
And the main thing about the telescreen is
not the existence of the telescreen in 1984,
it is the fact that it is one way.
Thereby enforcing power in a pyramidal structure.
If the telescreen operated two ways, and the
people, even the Proles, were able to listen
in on every secret party meeting.
It would not matter that the party has absolute
power of physical control.
Nevertheless, within a generation everything
would change.
It is not the equivalence of power that matters.
It is some degree of equivalence of knowledge.
There are all sorts of potential equalizers.
For instance, you as an individual can join
non-government organizations.
ACLU, electronic free- Electronic Frontier
Foundation, and all of these things.
By pooling together proxy power, you are enabling
them to hire professionals who are in range
of the professionals run by the Koch brothers.
These techniques exist.
These equalization techniques exist.
And we see this sort of thing happening all
the time.
And, a recent example was WikiLeaks.
I know the digital, top digital guy of Hillary
Clinton in the State Department.
And he said, he confirmed to me, that "If
she could give a secret medal without risking
anybody knowing about it, she would give a
medal and a great big wet kiss on the mouth
to Julian Assange."
Because, he created what democracy and transparency
is supposed to create for our public leaders.
And that's inconvenience.
He was highly irksome.
But that was it.
There were a couple dozen embarrassing cables
that he released.
And the storm over those went away.
Meanwhile, there were thousands of cables
released that showed our diplomats hating
Hosni Mubarak.
Hating the dictators that they had to work
with.
And totally within the cables being consistent
with our public statements.
The result was when the Arab spring burst,
and Assange says it was all because of him,
when the Arab spring burst there was not one
American flag burned.
There was not one hint of anti-Americanism
in the Arab spring.
In a large degree that is credited to the
fact that this asshole went ahead and leaked
a quarter of a million cables.
And the only loser out of this were our enemies
and that idiot who's going to go to prison
for the rest of his life.
Because he thought he was being an internet
hero.
And all he was blowing the whistle on was
people doing their jobs.
So, should we hurry through questions?
And those of you interested we could show
you that.
But, thank you very much.
You've been a lovely audience and go Google.
[applause]